freshman Congresswomen alexandria Ocasio
cortez Rashidah Talib and Ilhan Omar
prove the age old maxim at bottom all
political problems are theological
problems we will examine the politics of
religion the religion of politics from
Palestinian rockets to Pennsylvania
mosques to gospel hymns for the green
new deal
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
major violence in Israel over the
weekend big takeaways here are prominent
Democrats in the United States are
blaming the victims and they are siding
with terrorists against a United States
ally the reason why is that all politics
is ultimately about religion every
political question I know you think it
might not be every political question
ultimately boils down to a theological
question we'll see why in a second but
first we're never going to agree on
everything I think we can agree however
that we could all use more sleep I
certainly could I only got 17 hours last
night getting a great night's sleep is
easier and more affordable than you
think
you don't need a new expensive mattress
or sleeping pills you just need to
change your sheets that's why you should
check at Bowland branch everything
bowline branch makes from bedding to
blankets is made from 100% pure organic
cotton which means they start out super
soft and they get even softer over time
I used to sleep basically on sandpaper
then I got these sheets they are so
unbelievable they've stayed in a really
really nice hotel like twice in my life
and it feels just like that I didn't
realize you could get them at home
because luxury sheets can cost up to a
thousand bucks in the store with Boleyn
branch there are only a couple hundred
bucks they cut out the middleman send
them right to you everyone who tries
Boleyn branch loves them that's why they
have thousands of five-star reviews even
three u.s. presidents sleep on Bowl and
branch sheets treat yourself like a
president shipping is free you can try
them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a refund but I
doubt that you'll want to send them back
there's no risk and no reason not to
give them a try to get started right now
my listeners get $50 off your first set
of sheets at Boleyn branch calm promo
code michel mi CH AE L go to Boleyn
branch calm today for $50 off your first
set of sheets Bo ll and branch dot-com
promo code Michael mi CH AE L Boleyn
branch comm promo code Michael major
violence erupting in Israel ultimately
this story the story out of Pennsylvania
the story with AOC in the green new deal
all of this boils down to a religious
question so what specifically is
happening in
Israel Islamic terrorists in Gaza
launched over 600 rockets at Israel Iron
Dome which is their defense system was
able to intercept 173 of those rockets
obviously it's not going to intercept
all of them four people at least have
been killed dozens have been wounded why
is the violence breaking out I think the
the israel-palestine Middle Eastern
conflict is so complicated it goes back
so far it involves so many religious
questions I think a lot of Americans
just say all right I don't want any I
don't want anything to do with it never
mind I don't care I don't who knows it's
very complicated fair enough you can at
least understand a few pieces of it
because it's not just about Israel it's
not just about the Arabs in Israel and
outside of Israel it's not just about
the other countries in the region this
involves the United States as well how
so the big cause here for this attack I
believe is that Donald Trump is no
longer kowtow to the Iranian regime to
the illegitimate mullah Islamic regime
in Iran he's no longer sending them
pallets full of cash on airplanes like
Barack Obama did he's no longer thanking
them for abducting our sailors like
Obama did he is taking a hard line he
has a very strong national security
adviser in John Bolton and they are
saying no we're not going to be pushed
around by this thug illegitimate regime
in Iran deal with it so the US when a
when Trump came into power got us out of
that awful Iran deal hampered Iran's
ability to get a weapon and reinstituted
sanctions against the Iranian regime
meanwhile our ally Israel has targeted
Iranian interests in Syria and they have
gone after Iranian interests in direct
military strikes so now what Iran has
been doing is saying that they're going
to strike back at both the US and Israel
through proxies so they're going to use
groups like Hamas in Gaza they're gonna
use groups like Islamic Jihad they're
gonna use the terrorist groups that they
have funded for decades and they are
going to strike at US interests and
they're gonna strike at our ally in
Israel so what is the United
it's doing now the United States has
deployed an aircraft carrier the USS
Abraham Lincoln Carrier Strike Group and
a bomber task force to the region to
send a message that we are not going to
take provocation lying down John Bolton
one of the greatest characters in the
history of American diplomacy came out
and he issued a message to Iran he said
quote the United States is not seeking
war with the Iranian regime but we are
fully prepared to respond to any attack
whether by proxy the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard Corps or regular
Iranian forces so the violence begins in
particular how the violence begins when
a terrorist group called Islamic Jihad
used a sniper to shoot Israeli troops
and wounded two of those Israeli troops
last week that's what began this spate
of violence then there was there were
repercussions to that then there were
rockets fired from Gaza and and then you
get this violence that we've seen now
for five or six days how did members of
Congress in the United States respond to
this well two members in particular
Democrat members Rasheeda Talib and
Ilhan Omar those freshman
representatives far left-wing how did
they respond they defended the
terrorists of course first Rashida to
leave retweeted someone who was
criticizing a New York Times story so
the tweet that she retweeted said quote
this is a stunningly irresponsible and
misleading headline New York Times
Israel shot dozens of unarmed
Palestinian protesters in Gaza on Friday
and killed four Palestinians including
two protesters in Gaza before any
projectiles were launched okay now that
tweet that Rashida to leave retweeted is
itself misleading because what it's
suggesting is that Israel provoked the
rocket attacks Israel didn't provoke the
Iraq and attacks Iran acting through
Islamic Jihad provoked the response from
Israel which then led to rocket attacks
because a terrorist sniper started
firing on Israeli troops so what this
person is suggesting
is that when terrorists from Gaza start
firing on Israeli troops what Israel
should do is nothing they should just
take it lying down no come on we
shouldn't it would be wrong to fight
back against terrorists shooting our
troops that's what that lunatic says but
the more troubling thing is that a
member of the United States Congress
then retweeted that Islamist propaganda
now Talib keeps pushing the propaganda
okay
she then pushes her own tweet it says
quote when will the world
stop dehumanizing our Palestinian people
who just want to be free I'll just pause
there for a second did you catch that
our Palestinian people are we talking
about some group of Palestinian Arabs
living in New Jersey or some group of
Palestinian Arabs living in Arizona no
who are our Palestinian people who does
Talib refer to as our who does she view
as us who is she lying herself with our
people who just want to be free the
tweet goes on headlines like this and
framing it in this way just feed into
the continued lack of responsibility on
Israel who unjustly oppress and target
Palestinian children and families
hashtag free Palestine so this is pure
terrorists propaganda it's the only way
to put it a member of Congress Rasheeda
Talib is has become a mouthpiece for
some of the worst terrorists in the
world that's you know I don't there's no
more diplomatic way I could say it and
listen the more interesting thing I mean
I've I've suspected this for a long time
with Rasheeda Talib it's clear she
doesn't like Israel it's clear she
doesn't like Jews and it's clear that
she sides with some of the worst
terrorists in the world but listen to
the language she chose she's siding with
a group these this group of Arabs in
so-called Palestine that elected Hamas
to be their government that elected a
terrorist organization to be their
government she's siding with them over
an actual ally and a western-style
democracy in the Middle East but the
language three
Palestine the people just want to be
free we've talked about this theme for
weeks now this theme that goes
throughout all of Western modernity
which is liberation emancipation we
always want to emancipate we always want
to liberate we always want to be free
free is good not free is bad who could
disagree with that well what happens
when freedom means the opposite of
freedom this is why you've always got to
watch out for people who only speak in
the terms of abstract rights human
rights liberty equality fraternity
whenever they're just talking in those
totally abstract terms that are not
connected to anything on the ground that
are not connected to actual legal rights
that are not connected to actual people
in actual places with actual
institutions when they're just using
those words chances are they're
demagogues chances are they're trying to
trick you when she says free she means
Arabs in this region get another state
that's what she they just want to be
free how many Muslim states are there in
the region how many dozens of Muslim
states are there in the region there's
one Jewish state in the world there are
dozens of Muslim states in that region
and now she's saying we need to take
away part of the Jewish state to have
another Muslim state otherwise these
Arabs can't be free okay now now what
would that state look like if let's
let's just totally indulge the left's
preference here and say we're gonna give
them freedom we're gonna give them a
state what would that state look like
we'll get to in a second but first admit
it you think that cybercrime is
something that happens to other people
not you nobody wants your data right
hackers can't possibly grab your
passwords or credit card details but
you'd be wrong stealing data from
unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi is
one of the simplest and cheapest ways
for hackers to make money and something
tells me that you probably look at some
pretty weird websites on the internet
you probably look at some sites that you
wouldn't want to get out in the public
you know what I'm talking about late at
night you close the blinds turn the
lights off read the daily wire yeah I
think we understand each other you
could be writing your passwords and
credit card numbers on a huge billboard
for the rest of the world to see which
is why I decided to take action to
protect myself I use Express VPN
expressvpn secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing by encrypting your
data and hiding your public IP address
expressvpn use is easy to use apps that
run seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone or tablet turning it on
it takes just one click using expressvpn
you can safely surf on public Wi-Fi
without being snooped on without having
your personal data stolen for less than
seven bucks a month you can get the same
protection that I have expressvpn is the
number one VPN service by TechRadar and
rated by TechRadar comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee protect your online
activity today find out how you can get
three months free it expressvpn comm
slash michael that is expr ESS VPN comm
slash michael for three months free with
a one-year package expressvpn comm /
michael mi CH AE l to learn more let's
take Rashid its leaves tweet on the
surface just at its face value they want
to be free and to be free they need a
state what would that state look like it
would be a state run by Hamas you would
be giving the terrorist organization
Hamas which targets civilians doesn't
just accidentally kill civilians targets
civilians women and children uses them
as bulletproof vests not bulletproof for
the women and children uses them as as
protection from bombs and guns you would
be giving them a country free would me a
free free Palestine would mean giving
international recognition to a group of
people that intentionally undermine the
international order you'd be giving a
nation to people who undermine our
system of nation-states it is a freedom
that would undercut everybody else's
freedom
Ilhan omar actually goes further than
Rasheeda Talib she tweets out quote how
many more protesters must be shot
Rockets must be fired and little kids
must be killed until the endless cycle
of violence ends the status quo of
occupation and humanitarian crisis in
Gaza is unsustainable only real justice
can bring about security and lasting
peace
how many more protesters must be shot
how many more rockets must be fired I
don't know tell the people in Gaza to
stop firing rockets it's up to them not
up to Israel they're the ones firing the
Rockets they're the ones killing the
little kids it's not an endless cycle of
violence necessarily it's an endless
cycle of violence because terrorists in
Gaza keep firing on a legitimate state
and in part the only blame that Israel
deserves and this is that they haven't
simply wiped out that government of
Hamas that terrorist organization
completely that they haven't just strung
up every single one of those filthy
terrorists one after another that's
that's the only blame that Israel
deserves in this case is that they
haven't been harsher on Hamas terrorists
now what what Israel is saying is what
can't be harsher on Hamas terrorists
because Hamas terrorists are using
civilians as human shields and so we
don't want to kill all of these
civilians fair enough honorable position
to hold but the endless cycle of
violence is being uniformly pushed by
terrorists Islamists in Hamas in and and
other terrorist organizations in that
region how many more how many more
rockets is Islamic Jihad going to launch
blaming the victim that's what omar is
doing that's what Talib is doing so why
are they siding with the terrorists the
reason they're siding with the
terrorists is that all political
problems ultimately are theological
problems ultimately what what it seems
to me judging from Ilhan Omar's tweets
for instance judging from statements
that they've made judging from them
giggling at Islamic terrorist
organizations what it seems to me is
they're denying Jews claim to Israel
they're denying Jews religious claim to
Israel and they are denying Jews
historical claim to Israel the religion
the the people in the religion have
informed the history of that region and
so they deny the historical claim now
historically Muslims have also made a
claim to Jerusalem what is the Muslim
claim to Jerusalem a lot of people don't
know this because most people haven't
read the Quran the Muslim claim to
Jerusalem is a little weaker than the
Jewish claim to Jerusalem the Muslim
claim to Jerusalem is
that one night Muhammad was mystically
lifted up from Mecca and he was
transported on a mythical creature to
Jerusalem and then there all these other
things that kind of seemed like fever
dreams that come out of it so the claim
is he was mystically on a on a winged
horse brought from Mecca to Jerusalem we
don't have any evidence of course that a
winged horse brought Mohammed to
Jerusalem but that is the claim it's
based on a story in the Quran so the
political question boils down to
religion which religious group has a
claim to the land and and moreover what
is the difference between Jews and Arabs
in the region you're talking about two
different peoples in exactly the same
place and yet they have very different
societies very different cultures why is
that is it some racial issue is it that
Arabs are just less able to govern
themselves than ethnic Jews I don't
think so I don't think there's any
evidence for that is it even culture
primarily I don't know what what is
culture culture comes from cult culture
comes from the two words by the way
culturing cult are linked etymologically
they both come from the same place what
it means is it's like Andrew Breitbart
said politics is downstream from culture
culture is downstream of what the
culture worships religion so you've got
these two religions you've got the
people informed by Judaism and and also
from the West which was formed by
Judaism but and also Christianity and
also Greek philosophy and you've got a
culture that is informed by Islam and
they form different peoples they form
different politics they form different
claims to land and they form different
alliances so the strategic question for
the United States is who would we rather
Ally ourselves with would we rather Ally
ourselves with Israel or with Hamas
would you rather allow yourself with
Bibi Netanyahu who during the
administration of Barack Obama was the
leader of the free world or would you
rather allow yourself with Hamas
terrorists western-style democracy or
Islamist rogues
of states what would you rather allow
yourself with you can make the religious
question even more tangible if you look
move out of Israel and you go to
Philadelphia the Philadelphia chapter of
the Muslim American Society posted a
video over the past few days of little
kids talking about chopping off heads
I'll narrate this because they're
singing in Arabic these are kids maybe
six 12 years old and they're singing
those who accept humiliation what is the
point in their existence those who
reject oppression are the ones who
assert their existence and they
eliminate injustice from the land of the
Arabs rebels rebels rebels they're
wearing Palestinian head scarves as well
glorious steeds call us and lead us on
two paths leading to the al-aqsa mosque
in Jerusalem the blood of martyrs
protects us paradise needs real men the
land of the Prophet Muhammad's Night
Journey is calling us Jerusalem our
Palestine must return to us o Saladin
your men are among us shame will be
washed away you need force and the Quran
o free people we must persevere no
matter what happens and with the help of
the omnipotent Lord day will follow
night take us oh ship Santilli liberate
our lands until we reach our shores and
crush the treacherous ones blow a winds
of paradise flow rivers of martyrs my
Islam is calling who's going to heat its
call rise o righteous ones our martyrs
sacrificed their lives without
hesitation they attained paradise on the
scent of musk emanates from their bodies
they compete with one another to reach
paradise will Jerusalem be their capital
city or will it be a hotbed for cowards
they mean Jews by the way we will defend
the land of divine guidance with our
bodies and we will sacrifice our souls
without hesitation we will chop off
their heads and we will liberate the
soul ruffle and exalted al-aqsa mosque
we will lead the army of Allah
fulfilling his promise and we will
subject them to eternal torture six to
twelve year old kids
posted by a mosque in Philadelphia not
in Jerusalem not in Gaza not nope not in
Mecca Philadelphia this is being posted
by the Muslim American Society now the
person who posted that allegedly has
been fired the president of the Muslim
American Society the executive director
says this video does not represent our
understanding of Islam nor the
understanding of the mainstream Muslim
community I hope that's true I don't
know if it's true it's pretty weird that
they would post that video it's pretty
weird that that video exists this is the
religious question so in America we
always ignore the actual religious
question we ignore the deep questions of
our politics in part it's because our
system is built on religious freedom but
part of that religious freedom is that
we won't stop start chopping off each
other's heads part of that religious
freedom is a tacit agreement among all
of us that we won't do with those little
six year olds in the video we're singing
about and chop off people's heads and
and exalt in their blood
if religious freedom encourages people
to start chopping off people's heads for
believing in Christianity or Judaism you
have undercut the entire point of that
religious freedom G K Chesterton has
this line he wrote there is a thought
that stops thought and that is the only
thought that ought to be stopped there
is a religious freedom that stops
religious freedom what how could that
possibly be true religious freedom at a
certain point in the conversation when
you're talking about politics and
culture and religion the phrase
religious freedom is not enough in our
culture we're so into this right now we
say you do you don't you cry um well
that's your you you can do whatever you
want to do and I'll do whatever I want
to do and we don't need to talk about
the thing itself all we're just talking
about freedom we're all free we can do
whatever we want you sometimes have to
get to the ideas themselves politics is
down from culture culture is down from
religion and some time
you have to say not all religions are
the same you don't see the Catholic
parish in Philadelphia making videos of
six-year-olds talking about chopping off
people's heads you don't see the
Methodists in Philadelphia making videos
about chopping off people's heads and
posting them to their Facebook pages
there are different religious views and
those different religious views create
different cultures and those different
cultures have different politics and you
can't just assume that you can take one
politics the politics informed by by
chopping off people's heads and throw it
into the West and it'll all be exactly
fine and it'll all be the same and
everyone will get along no that's not
how it works we're very open in the West
because our politics is formed by a real
openness by a real toleration not
everybody agrees with those ideas and to
make an idol out of those then is to
invite your own death is to invite the
destruction of those ideas themselves
it's cultural suicide the left has very
weird religious ideas I don't know how I
can make this point any clearer you
could forget about Islam just look at
the religion of leftism this was the
clearest in Ilhan Omar and Rashid its
leaves colleague Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes she sang a gospel song for the
green new deal and it's it is truly the
funniest video that has come out of
politics in the last many weeks but you
can only see it if you go to daily
wire.com 10 bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
end reclaim and show you get the men
Shapiro's show you get to ask questions
in the mailbag you get the mount wall
show you get to ask questions backstage
you get another Kingdom you get the
leftist here's tumblr when we start
playing that aoc gospel song the leftist
tears are going to flow go over to daily
wire calm we'll be right back
[Music]
the left has very strange religious
ideas I have said this for a while now
but the big takeaway watching this a OC
video the left not only perverts reality
the left inverts it the left takes
reality and exactly flips it on its head
it makes it opposite day every single
day the other point that is so clear
that again I know we have all been
intuiting this for years now but it's so
explicit here global warming is a false
religion it's not about science it's not
about scholarship it's not about studies
it is a false religion with all the
trappings of religion including now
apparently gospel hymn Sunday before
last
AOC shows up in a nice white shirt she
goes out with a group of these women all
wearing white singing a gospel song and
across the post that she makes on
Instagram it says hashtag green new deal
you are not going to believe the song
she decided to sing in defense of the
green new deal
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the world didn't give it the world can't
take it away
did you catch those lyrics that were
only like two lyrics in the song this
joy that I have the world didn't give it
to me the world didn't give it the world
can't take it away therefore we need to
protect the natural world hold on wait a
second all right let me go back
ironically sometimes I think she's just
trolling us at this point ironically the
song that AOC is singing in defense of
the green New Deal is the strongest
argument there is against the green New
Deal her song that she's singing is the
joy that I have doesn't come from this
world this this is a gospel song it's
called this joy that I have and it's a
old-timey gospel song it's a great one
it's a song about spiritual endurance
and grit and grace from God it's saying
the joy that I have in my heart that
animates me that lifts me up is not from
this world it's not from the trees it's
not from the birds it's not from the
sunset it's not from my material wealth
it's not even from my health it's not
from any of the physical things of this
world this joy that I have comes from
somewhere else now you'll notice in the
version that AOC is singing they just
keep repeating that this joy that I have
the world didn't give it to me the world
didn't give it the world can't take it
away the actual song has many more
lyrics to it I'll just play you one of
them from an excellent version of this
song by Shirley Caesar see if you can
catch the word that AOC left out
[Music]
Jesus
nobody bejesus but in the aoc version
she'd have to sing like like solar power
nobody but solar power windmills know
about air but windmills that's what she
started those paper straws oh definitely
not plastic straws paper straws because
what a o'seas fake false religion of
global warming does is inverts true
religion this joy that I have tells me
that everything in this world will pass
away everything in this world is gonna
pass away
I'm gonna die someday too you all are
hate to break it to spoiler alert every
material thing that you really like that
new shirt that you bought that you think
really looks good on you
your friends your family your kid all of
those things are going away they are not
going to last one day the Sun won't rise
this earth will pass our galaxy will
pass it's all going away this joy that I
have comes from eternal things that are
outside of this world
they're from my salvation my Savior my
Creator the divine logic of the universe
now the point of that song is that we
don't need to worry about the sufferings
of this world we don't need to worry
about the natural and physical world at
all it's gonna pass we've got something
eternal
and what aoc is singing is that we've
got to care about the natural and
physical world most of all because i'm
singing a part of a pretty gospel song
this is what the left always does the
the left loves the appearance of
beautiful things but they hate what
makes the things beautiful so they let
their all wearing white white is a sign
of purity
since when does the left like purity
since when does the left like modesty
the left goes on [ __ ] walks and shout
your abortion walks they don't like
people but they like the imagery of
purity
since when does
left appreciate the gospel and gospel
music and gospel songs they don't
believe in Jesus they are substituting a
false religion for the religion of
Christianity of Jesus but they like but
they don't it looks good Christianity
it's so pretty it looks so good
those gospel songs look good the group
she's singing with the resistance
revival chorus they actually sound
pretty good they are quote a collection
of more than 60 women who come together
to sing protest songs in the spirit of
collective joy and resistance so they're
just far left when you're singing
protest songs but that is not a protest
song this joy I have is a gospel song
it's about the good news what's the good
news that the world can't take this away
cuz the world doesn't really matter what
are they singing exactly the opposite
everybody's got to serve somebody just
keep that little song in mind the next
time some global warming alarmist comes
up to you and says you're denying
science global warming is about science
it's about scientific studies you're a
science denier say hmm I don't think
that a oh see singing this joy I have
with a bunch of left-wing activists
don't think that's very scientific I
don't I don't think the green New Deal
is very scientific is it I don't think
it's even really primarily about the
environment
it's about a universal basic income it's
about socialist health care it's about a
whole lot of things that have nothing to
do with the natural environment this is
what a culture that doesn't know itself
does we're born into this culture even
the most radical left-wing people in our
culture are born into it and they they
kind of like it they have a familiarity
with it they like the gospel songs they
like the white dress they like the dance
and around or they like that they don't
know what it means they're just saying
words they don't know what they mean I
mean in this case she is literal she
might as well be singing the green New
Deal doesn't matter and I shouldn't care
about global warming the green new deal
doesn't matter and she's basically
singing those words but she she doesn't
hear them she doesn't know what they
mean it is ace
senseless culture at this point that
doesn't know itself that's going through
the motions without knowing what the
motions mean you see this perversity you
see this exact backwards miss it back we
got to go back to Pennsylvania
unfortunately with there's a
pennsylvania state representative this
guy Brian Sims and he goes out to a
Planned Parenthood and he says that he's
out there supporting women's rights and
how is he gonna support women's rights
by harassing and mocking and ridiculing
a woman who is expressing her political
views here is this guy this this Punk
this despicable punk
Brian Sims going out on the streets
right in front of a Planned Parenthood
to harass a woman who was protesting the
killing of babies everyone
representative Brian Sims here and I'm
once again out in front of Planned
Parenthood of southeastern Pennsylvania
it's not only in my district it's the
most heavily protested Planned
Parenthood I believe in the country and
today's protester now she is an old lady
who's gonna try to avoid showing you her
face but the same laws and luckily that
protect her from being out here also
protect me from showing you who she is
and so my hope is is that you'll donate
a hundred dollars for every extra hour
that this woman is out here telling
people what's right for their bodies so
have a couple questions for you ma'am
how many children have you clothed today
I'm sorry I missed your answer how many
children have you closed today
how about how many children have you put
shoes on their feet today have you fed
any children today or have you just
stood out in front of a Planned
Parenthood shaming people for something
that they have a constitutional right to
do you can pray at home for children
it's probably the same place you can
feed a child but you're not instead
you're out here shaming people person a
that they have a constitutional right to
do who'd have thought that an old white
lady would be out in front of a Planned
Parenthood telling people what's right
for their bodies shame on you shame on
you for hiding your face at the same
time that you're shaming other people so
this guy obviously has some presumably
pretty bad psychological problems he's
an elected politician in Pennsylvania
he's got a lot of bad philosophical and
political and I suspect religious
problems too so his do you hear his
premise so he goes up and he says how
many kids have you clothed today how
many kids have you bought shoes for
today while you were protesting the
point is if you think that it's wrong to
kill babies you also need to buy
clothing for lots of little kids which
is a complete non sequitur that doesn't
make any sense you can it is perfectly
reasonable to think that you shouldn't
murder babies and also that their
parents should take care of them and
like not me but but beyond that study
after study shows Republicans
right-wingers gives significantly more
to charity than left wingers do this has
been shown time and time again it's true
of individuals it's true of counties
it's true of states there was a 2012
study that showed that the eight most
generous states this states that gave
the highest percentage of their income
to charity all voted for the Republican
in 2008 and the seven least generous
states the ones that give the lowest
percentage of their income to charity
all voted for the Democrat in 2008 so
even if his premise were true which it's
not that if you think we shouldn't kill
babies you also should donate to charity
all the people who think we shouldn't
kill babies donate more to charity than
the people who think we should kill
babies even that is wrong but do you
know what the major
factor is here is religion so a lot of
these studies show it's not exactly just
political preferences it's that
political preferences come from cultural
ones which come from religious ones and
it's the religion that is dictating the
charitable giving which of course makes
sense the the impulses that I have to
give to charity are informed by my
religion I suspect yours are too if you
think that life is some cosmic joke that
it doesn't mean anything it's all random
that's suffering and pleasure and pain
they're all just sort of illusions that
my pleasure is in no way less important
than you were pain why would you ever
give your money to somebody else why
would you do that doesn't make any sense
the whole world doesn't make sense under
that strange religion but religion is
the factor and this guy Brian Simms
posted on Twitter all of these anti
Christians screeds
he said all you Bible bullies don't want
to kill kids but you know you should
something like that Christians give much
more to charity the most charitable
organization in the history of the world
by fall I mean there is no second place
is the Catholic Church it's not the
atheist League of southeastern
Pennsylvania it's not the Democrat House
of Representatives in Pennsylvania club
it's the Catholic Church those Bible
bullies well as Christians give much
more to charity but then the biggest
irony I love this so much in the video
is he's harassing this poor woman for
nine consecutive minutes is he decides
to show what what real feminism looks
like thank you so much for working in a
place that respects and protects women
thank you so much so if you couldn't see
it that's Brian Simms turning to two men
walking into Planned Parenthood licking
their chops can't wait to get their
hands on a couple new babies two men
walking in and then this man turns to
them and says thank you for supporting
women not like this old hag over here
not like this awful vicious hag whose
face I'm screaming in and who I'm
plastering on social media this awful
awful broad no you men you guys really
know how to support women and this awful
hag is a real misogynist huh
that's what he
say he's accused he did this on Twitter
later he accused people who disagree
with his tactic of harassing a woman
mocking her appearance mocking her age
plastering her on social media he
accused those of us who criticized that
of misogyny of hatred of women this guy
Brian Simms is the face of misogyny this
is what misogyny looks like but it's
that same it's that backwards day
opposite day they can't see it it's why
I think Alexandria o cassia Cortes is
trolling us sometimes is she says things
that are the opposite of the argument
she thinks she's making but she doesn't
realize it
Rasheeda Talib Ilhan Omar they're
talking about freedom they're talking
about justice they're talking about
defense they're talking about oppression
and yet they are seeing the situation
exactly backwards
the violent aggressors they are
defending as the victims the victims
they are accusing is the oppressors the
rogue state that elected a terrorist
organization it's not a state it's a
random area that elected a terrorist
organization they want to turn into a
state and yet the legitimate state the
western-style democracy in the Middle
East they smear as a rogue state true
religion the left mocks false religion
hopeless religion the religion of matter
the religion of stuff the religion of
this world
the left exalts as the the pinnacle of
science and hope they might that the
left should have been singing in that
song the this joy that I have the the
world gave it to me the world gave it
and I guess the world can take it away
uh-oh better watch out they use the word
misogyny to mean the opposite of
misogyny they use the word the phrase
pro-woman
to mean the opposite of pro-woman it's
exactly the opposite and is it is it
exactly the opposite because they're
making a slight political miscalculation
is it exactly the opposite because they
got their tax rates a little bit wrong
oh they
underestimated economic growth in the
third quarter yeah they thought that
this one Ally would have a stronger
response to a provocation no it has
nothing to do with that basic politics
their political miscalculations their
political errors are fundamentally
religious errors that's how they go so
wrong
we were talking about this last week a
little bit how the phrase you can't
legislate morality doesn't make any
sense because all legislation ultimately
refers to the moral law whenever we use
the phrase fairness justice equality
we're referring to moral terms even tax
rates pay their fair share we're talking
about moral terms and so at the very
bottom when you if you make a moral
error if you make a religious error then
your political error is going to be so
magnified if you make a religious error
then your political error could be it
could be the exact opposite of the point
that you want to make if you think that
god is a god of sense logic the divine
logic of the universe perfect goodness
maximal greatness that is going to lead
to a certain culture into a certain
politics if you think that God is a God
of pure will that God is not bound in
any way by logic that God does not
necessarily have anything to do with
logic that's going to lead to another
kind of politics and if you believe as
the religion of leftism does that God
doesn't really exist at all you know
we're all sort of God man this whole
world is God mother nature is God Gaia
is God ultimately I'm my own God if you
believe that you are going to have
probably the most perverse politics of
all but it's going to be the funniest
one because it's exactly backwards it's
singing gospel songs to nothing singing
gospel songs without the gospel gospel
songs without the good news before we go
we only have a couple minutes left I
have to
talk about this Facebook banning there
was a major ban on Facebook that
happened we were off the air on Friday
they banned Infowars alex jones louis
farrakhan laura Loomer Paul Neil and
Paul Joseph Watson Milo yeah innopolis
the other social media sites have banned
a lot of other people as well this is
terrible there is no defense of this
there is and look some of these guys are
pretty bad hombres louis farrakhan
obviously is a horrific man a vicious
bigot terrible guy probably had a hand
in the killing of Malcolm X this is a
bad guy
Paul Nealon is a white supremacist he
ran for Congress in Wisconsin Milo you
Nautilus everyone's seen Milo you
innopolis is ups and downs and pitfalls
and bad decisions some of these guys are
basically mainstream or perfect or at
least innocuous maybe they're a little
quirky or they're a little odd
you know Paul Paul Joseph Watson works
for Infowars Infowars is a pretty
eccentric place but Pope Paul Joseph
Watson is not a bigot I've never seen
any evidence that that guy's bigoted at
all I've never seen Alex Jones you know
put on a Ku Klux Klan hood or or join
with a bunch of bigots or violent people
I've been you know in the last few days
I've seen two members of Congress
publicly defend violent terrorists who
launched 700 missiles at a civilian
population I've seen two members of
Congress do that I never saw Alex Jones
do that I never saw Milo yu-na police do
that never saw Paul Neyland do that I
never saw Paul Joseph Watson do that
Laura Loomer this is very calculated
what they are doing is they're mixing
some truly bad people you know Louis
Farrakhan is probably probably the worst
person on that list and he's been the
worst for a long time they mix some
really bad hombres in there too then
take out the innocuous people like Paul
Joseph Watson what this is building
toward is banning me banning drew
banning Matt banning Ben
banning all of the big names in the
mainstream right-wing they're gonna
start and I'll say what it doesn't
matter
look we just Milo you nah police is a
fringe character okay but why are you
banning him what's the point of banning
him oh look Infowars it's free you don't
wanna you're not like Infowars yeah okay
but why why are you banning them it's an
excuse because the left does not want
conservative ideas to get out and so
they're gonna muddy the waters they're
gonna mix things up and they're gonna
hope that conservatives aren't going to
defend Alex Jones I will defend Alex
Jones I will defend Alex Jones being on
any social media platform forever and I
will do it because there's no reason to
take them off and because taking him off
is just a hidden way to come after the
rest of us and any conservatives who
remain silent or are just appeasing that
little crocodile hoping that it will eat
them last that's our show come back
tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Moses is the Michael Nolt show see you
then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today a
United States congresswoman has taken
the side of terrorists and she even
referred to and I quote here she said
our Palestinian people our I want to
talk about that statement and I'll
explain why I think it warrants an
investigation into this woman also a
democratic state representative harassed
an elderly woman an elderly pro-life
woman and he was so proud of himself for
doing so that he recorded it and put it
online so we'll play a clip of that and
talk about it and I'll answer your
emails today over on the Matt Walsh show